hey guys i'm jeff mcdonald it's the 18th
of march and you're tuned into gamespot
news first up those of you in countries
that are still Xbox one list will be
sorted out come September of this year
Microsoft have confirmed that Japan and
the rest of Europe will get the box
later this year although you'll have to
wait till the end of April to find out
more about the availability of the
console in the 26 regions it will be
arriving in for that full list you can
check out our story on site now the
publisher also added that last week they
saw the highest numbers logged on to
xbox live since the launch of the xbox
one so basically titanfall happened next
up debs do have a tendency to jump ship
once the game is all wrapped up and
ready to go and today that dev is the
lead designer of infamous second son
Jamie carissima who also worked on
destiny halo reach and halo 3 has left
Sucker Punch productions although he's
told us through Twitter that he's not
prepared to discuss why when he was
prepared to offer up was that he is
super excited for people to get their
hands on infamous second son the ps4 has
got itself a system update this week and
if you happen to have one of those guys
this is what you'll be in for the 336
megabyte download is all set to improve
operation quality and yeah we don't know
what that means any more than you do
Sony have literally said quite simply in
reference to update 1.62 operation
quality during use of summer ps4 format
software has been improved you guys seem
to have taken this story is an
opportunity to talk about what you
actually do want included in a ps4
system update so let me know what that
might be in the comments down below if
you one of the people mildly upset about
the fact that metal gear solid ground
zeroes is all set to be able to be
completed in under two hours you're
probably not going to be happy to hear
that somebody's completed it in 10
minutes Eurogamer have posted a crazy
spoiler heavy video showing that it's
possible to knock off the entire game in
the time
time frames although the point needs to
be made that this is the work of a
speedrunner cutting through metal gears
notoriously long cutscenes and ignoring
side mission content so you're unlikely
to find that you've spent 20 bucks on a
game which is costing you two dollars a
minute if you're a fan of story in games
you may want to simmer down the
inevitable rage here because the League
of Legends designer has said that it's
highly overrated Tom Abernathy made the
comments regarding plot during GDC and
went on to say that uses don't remember
plot they remember characters he thinks
developers should focus on the things
that they will retain that being the
characters who inhabit game worlds and
not the story around them mostly you
guys are fairly consistently pointing
out the fact that this is coming from a
morbid eva's genre which is not known
for its focus on plot let me know how
important you think plot is in games and
where do you reckon we can do without it
either in the comments down below or you
can let me know your thoughts on my
Twitter where I'm at Jess McDonald that
is it for me today but where there is
more news they'll definitely be more GS
news and I'm pretty sure that's gonna be
same time tomorrow so see them